you got to think that the last time
there was a film with so many basketball
stars in it was Space Jam in the Latin
comedy that included a plotline where
everybody had to get the band back
together it's like Blues Brothers you
put it all together and you've got uncle
drew in theaters near you on June 29th
starring in part my next guest who's
sitting right here and the Los Angeles
Rich Eisen show studio here the 18 C
studio Lisa Leslie good to see you Lisa
so you play the preacher's wife in this
film Betty Lou Betty Lou gets buckets
Jesus and Betty Lou gets buckets and the
preacher is c-webb right Chris Webber is
a preacher in the idea I mean obviously
I'm the first lady of the church and we
have left basketball behind us and you
know it's all about the Lord and so my
role as Betty Lewis I don't want
preacher to get back into that other
world to get back into that van is where
you know some things went down when they
were younger right uncle drew and
everybody else was of age and here you
are was showing a shot of the of the
film the calm before the storm divine
ministries yes delayed with you coming
out with a baseball bat looking all
sorts of mean is not play so that's the
Lisa lesson you know on the court you
know so it's it was it was a lot of fun
I think it's a laugh-out-loud movie
people will enjoy it and it's a really
good message as well while Kairi
obviously his uncle drew Shaq as big
fellow si Weber's the preacher Reggie
Miller is lights Nate Robinson as boots
and you are Betty Lou I mean so which
basketball player in this film is the
best comedic actor do you think Lisa
Leslie well I would say each character
really does a great job and you're gonna
be surprised most people had been who've
seen the movie already about how well
everyone's acting is I think each
character really comes to life but I
would say you know Shaq is probably had
the most experience aside from myself in
acting and he's just natural I mean he's
there's things it's not written in a
script that he does that's hilarious and
so I would probably say she can he
he had lived the most not necessarily
Ali but yeah yeah absolutely he added
things that was not in a script that
really made it funny
so you're saying without Kazaam he would
not have had this absolutely was really
that and they don't forget about what's
the other one blue chips yeah I guess
that's true blue chip well blue chips
had Shack in it a long time ago these
guys were just about to be pros I think
they had just gotten drafted yeah so he
said that he has the most experience
then I do I've been in what you what
what are what else what is your other
filmography things like man I've been in
that loving basketball he might see me
in that's right yeah basketball so you
enjoying that you like oh I love acting
I felt like acting is the closest thing
that we get to babe to basketball the
filling of the adrenaline if you will
you know that fire that burns within
when you share a screen with someone
else and try to make that come to life
is so much well you know who's in our
third hour
speaking of love and basketball from
fatherless to fatherhood that's a great
time that's his new book yeah he's
coming in an hour number three you have
any good Omar up stories that I can drop
no other than being a fan I don't know
Omar it's okay I'm just throwing that
out there yeah okay Lisa Leslie here on
the Rich Eisen show it just looks like
you had so much fun doing this that
there was just so much fun on the set I
mean we have behind the scenes of you
with Shaq him and Nate Robinson they
really like the same person Nate's the
smallest five nine right and Shaq
obviously seven feet and these guys are
hilarious Nate dunked on Shaq so many
time his whole goal was just a dunk on
Shaq so we had a lot of fun when you say
so you there was an actual yeah you
didn't see that video with Nate doctor
no Shaq yeah so I was talking to
Shaquille under the rim and here comes
Nate Nate's goal is to dunk on anybody
standing under the rim he has this
ongoing game so he dunked on a little
rail the actor the comedian he dunks
over Shaq yes so how did the out of the
pickup game come about just bored him on
the set or something like yeah anytime
you have basketball players standing on
the court and there's a ball we're gonna
shoot we're gonna play we played [ __ ]
I mean Betty Lou really shacks online
telling you barely Betty Lou got the
most buckets of everybody so that
you said you got buckets you don't mean
in the film you're talking about off off
camera you mean it wasn't written in for
Betty Lou to score that much so you know
they had to cut all of that out
otherwise it caused Betty Lou and that
uncle drill so who won who won horse on
the side Betty no what was your shot
that nobody could get just making more
bucks it no matter what the shot is you
just got to make more buckets and
everyone did you try to make a free
throw is that why is that how you do I
did left-handed free throws
cuz I'm ambidextrous did Shaq trying
left-handed free throw Jack was out
before we started a shoe he can't see
from the outside he was out so real
let's see ty read myself and Nate
Robinson where the last three we knocked
out Reggie Miller can you believe it no
please walk me through this one please
yes okay
Reggie Miller got knocked out I got
knocked out in the game of horse and
Horus last standing Kyrie
Lisa Leslie Nate Robinson
Kyrie loses Nate and I were left and
then we had to go back to work so who's
so Shaq was first knocked down yeah
shackle you know second checks out raizy
miller out see Webb out yes see Webb
anyway about it was the left-handed free
throw to guys see Webb
I just love it that lil rel is actually
thinking there could be some hang with
this horse game that he can actually
hang who is the best because you as you
know you know how it works as you say
they're immature love acting so many act
so many players want to be actors
actresses musicians yes everybody else
wants to be actors actresses musicians
one of the athletes yeah who is the best
hoop playing actor actress musician
you've ever been around ever yes
Oh Brian McKnight probably would be the
best basketball player yeah of like
actors and actors um for sure he's
really good
Chris Brown is an excellent basketball
player as well and then there's also
master P who went to the NBA
well actually Master P's number one
Master P's never won he went to the NBA
where does Kevin Hart rank Kevin's up
there kevin has amazing jumpers Kevin
can shoot the three-ball like people
think because he's small Kevin don't
sleep on Kevin part he can play really
yes
does he like Duncan on people
I don't know I don't think you can dunk
but he can shoot because I wasn't things
like a man with him when we shot some
scenes in the gym he can shoot he really
can yes because I know he's in all these
you know celebrity all-star events and
he wins MVPs you can play so that's not
a setup
thank you Kevin Hart gets buckets like
that right when we come back I want to
ask you your thoughts on what's going on
in the NBA with LeBron obviously up in
July and Kauai coming here everybody
thinks you know obviously you you know a
lot about basketball in Southern
California with the Lakers especially
yes
everybody thinks Kauai is gonna open the
door for LeBron to come here and I want
to get your two cents on that in fact in
60 seconds with lisa leslie who you can
follow on twitter at lisa leslie and
also right here on the Rich Eisen show
when we come back we'll talk about your
broadcasting career and what you're
doing down in florida with some some
kids and your charity work as well lisa
leslie when we come back here in a
minute
lisa leslie here on the Rich Eisen show
what was that like how big do you think
that was Mike at the moment I was just
really pissed we were losing to Miami so
I remember not being happy with our team
and I was in the huddle kind of just
busing like we got it someone we got to
close this gap and so and I was talking
about it's going to start on defense and
so that was kind of what happened before
we came out and we were on defense and
my teammate got that passed and she out
led it to me and I'm like I was trying
to think of what I could do to inspire
my teammates really it was what that was
what was in my head and so I'm like I
got to go for it you know so she threw
it to me and I dunked it and then after
I dunked it I think the magnitude of it
just sort of was like oh yeah I don't do
it like I dunked it I did it without
thought but then once I dunked it I was
realized like wow yeah well I mean I'm
sure you you've done it many many times
not any game well I had done it in
summer leagues and things like that but
not what's considered official in a WNBA
game I'm sure you've done it before
yeah so when people made a big deal of
it do you think it was a big deal I did
because I felt like at that time in the
league in 2001 too we would always have
the naysayers that we were in media sort
of like well
the women's game yeah they play good
they can't dunk something like dude even
if we dunk it doesn't make a difference
because by the time the NBA gets to the
playoffs how many dunks do we see not
many right it came it comes down to
execution and so because we play
basketball sort of the right way people
talk about talked about you know we
didn't have the dunk now we have women
Duncan all over the place it's like
doesn't matter who's the best you ever
played against move one player the best
ever the one that you just remember when
you played against this I would probably
have to say a list of people Diana
Taurasi Cynthia Cooper I always think
about the positions that I didn't play
that we couldn't stop them and I'm like
we're gonna lose because we can't shut
that one player down and it's been
probably those two players who were just
unstoppable so then give me the Mount
Rushmore of women's basketball the Mount
Rushmore wow I would say Cheryl Miller
Sheryl Swoopes Diana Taurasi in my own
there absolutely put yourself on there
Wow and then the last one wow that's
kind of tough well I mean you would make
the fourth that's it that was four but
we need a fifth player no you just
forged for you okay there you go if you
want to give a fifth to go go for it I
would say Katrina McLean okay yeah we
need to have that forward that game
well I remember being around Sports
Center in OH - when you did that did you
uh yes I loved bringing him up mention
his name do you ever meet Stuart Scott
yeah absolutely I love Stuart absolutely
you have any good memories of hanging
out with him well Stuart was he would do
we did the Gatorade Awards together
presentations and I mean stories just a
great guy what can you say it's just
it's that that we lost him but our
readers know yeah I know
yes that's why I like bringing his name
up cuz so many people you know I think
when I look on TV I'll say following in
his footsteps
instead of there's a lot of imitation
which is the greatest form of flattery
right true but I do remember he would
always talk you up whenever there was a
highlight he would want it for himself
yes he's doing a hot I really appreciate
him you know the thing about being in
sports is that I do appreciate the men
that are very respectful of the women
for us that are in sports that are
working just as hard and recognize that
and he's one of those guys who just
for us as well and wanted to make sure
we had sort of that platform yeah so you
did it you did an award show with him
yeah we would do the Gatorade I would
always award the best Gatorade Player of
the Year for the women and you know
there was another guy or whether it was
LeBron or Vince Carter a different guy
would award the men and so well Vince is
that Vince to those again I couldn't get
highlights when it was Jordan Vince
Carter yeah you were one of them too
just like that okay that Stewart you
even asked me that the other day there
was a video of Stewart that went viral
just last week really because yes it was
the anniversary of the Jordan flu game
and so Sports Center and ESPN put out
his his highlight him doing the
highlight on SportsCenter I was next to
him and so Kris over there asked me did
you did you even ask for it in May in
the show meeting like not just was like
you know what's doing I got this one I
got this one every day that's why I like
bringing him up when obviously somebody
who I feel that he respected and I
thought did you know might have met him
I like bring it up Lisa Leslie here on
the Rich Eisen show okay so what do you
think is gonna happen with LeBron Kawhi
you know there's Paul George out there -
everybody thinks that that Kawhi wanting
to come to Los Angeles
will be what opens the key to the door
for LeBron to walk through what do you
think Lisa well I think we're now in an
era where super teams are a must if you
want to win and I think Golden State's
really proved that they found so much
success with it so I know that LeBron
knows he cannot do it by himself I think
he's thinking long term long term is I
know he has a house in Los Angeles I
know that he enrolled his son in school
here in Los Angeles and I believe that
that move for him will be great it
helped parlay what he wants to do later
whether it's in movie and film and
things like that
and that way is lala land why wouldn't
you want to be here so with Kawhi
Leonard who I think being in a market
where he's always been considered that
number for best player 3 whenever you
have these conversations now will get a
steady digest of him seeing him for the
Los Angeles Lakers in that uniform will
give us an opportunity to recognize how
great of a player he is now if you can
combine LeBron
in Kauai you're covering offense and
defense from position one through five
you really have it on the floor the way
that they can defend will make anybody
else around them better
you have Randall who's on the Lakers
already who can defend at that four and
remember he has the size of LeBron but
LeBron can play any position at any time
he's also a very good defensive player
now in order to can be able to complete
compete with Golden State you have to be
able to play defense at a high level you
have to be top five in the whole league
with those three players on the court
they can do that now yet Kuzma or ball
or any of the young players they're
going to be able to get in line and do
some of the small intangible things but
I think they would put themselves in a
great position to be able to compete and
take down go to stay don't you think
though that some of the names you just
mentioned would have to wear a Spurs
you're gonna former and they're just
gonna wave oh I mean I know magic is
very persuasive but he can't just wave a
wand and get Kawhi here he's got to give
you know palinka and magic and the team
of gotta give something up significant
to go get Kawhi Leonard they have to
give up something but if you have a
player who does not want to no longer
play for your franchise they'll figure
out a way to to get the trade and get
whatever it is they want do they have
something that the that San Antonio
wants the type of player that Popovich
would want
hmm maybe and if the Lakers have to lose
that for LeBron and for Kawhi anybody's
gonna be worth it so it is a fact his
son is LeBrons
son is enrolled out here in California
allegedly okay reports it up just sure
so if that's the case then then then
he's coming here I didn't talk to LeBron
and LeBron didn't tell me that but this
is just from what I've heard through the
industry and from players that I know
definitely have your ear to the ground
more than obviously so yes for sure yeah
ha ok so then then let me ask you this
Lisa Leslie here on the Rich Eisen show
the idea that LeBron with his final
window of opportunity to win
championships which is obviously what
folks like yourself and LeBron this for
that's it that's it right obviously
outside of the family which we oh yeah
careers it's about winning if you you
don't win it wasn't a great seat
now that said though later in life you
want as less drama as possible doing
that would you think that LeBron would
come here
knowing that there's a teammate's dad
who could pop off about anything at any
time and create microphones coming to
LeBrons face and saying levar said this
levar said that I don't think that's a
part that's an issue because I don't at
all I think that would be completely
second and third dairy to his decision
with his family was most important his
legacy and how it can end playing for an
amazing franchise I mean being a part of
the Los Angeles Lakers history and
fabric would be amazing I think for
LeBron to end his career here and I
don't think levar ball is something that
he has to factor in you can't get any
more inside scoop than which you already
have with the cameras pretty much
following the team in the locker rooms
what they put out on social media on
themselves I don't think that that's
gonna play a factor in it so what about
the Clippers maybe because at least with
the Clippers he could create his own
legacy that's the only he would P would
be the only number up there essentially
as opposed to one of it and shoot you
you know what it looks like it's stable
in his play hey you know if it would
have been we've got to rebound maybe a
year back where Chris Paul was there I
had Blake and DeAndre together I would
say absolutely I thought that would be a
great story both in a way for him to
finish but now it's not the case that's
a totally different team and I think
they're much further away than the
Lakers are the last thing for you then
on this because you said that in this
day and age you gotta have a super team
to compete yeah do you like that I do
only because I know what it takes to win
championships it's not easy and Michael
Cooper used to always tell me you can
either help get us there or you can get
us help us to win it but you can't do
both and what that means it's the same
thing for LeBron LeBron had an amazing
regular season like I think he hopefully
will get the MVP because he just had a
great season and then to get them there
he needed help he couldn't win the whole
thing by himself he ran out of gas and
so you need help to win a championship
the championship is different basketball
and this is the part that I do hate
about playing and when it comes to the
championship the rules change right like
things that were fouls for example
harden harden goes through the middle
all the time with this Euro step and all
that he gets that call ninety-nine
percent of the time he gets to the plows
what happens it's not a foul anymore
that's the difficult part is when you're
in the playoffs you have to be tougher
stronger you have to fight through
things that used to be fouls and
regular-season are alone no longer fouls
when you get to the playoffs and he got
beat down I mean what else could LeBron
have done with the team he had this year
I know he said that pretty much too and
he got some grief for it I know that's
it you got like three deuce on your back
you take over 45 50 points and you know
what we're such a we're in a time where
we're so like oh man that wasn't enough
it's never enough it's never enough that
guy is a may he's great like great and
it's hard for people to appreciate it
because why people that are sitting
around who don't even they've never even
played basketball who couldn't make a
basket and you watch this guy and
critique him start to finish alright so
before I let you go here uncle drew in
theaters near you on the 29th of June
and you're you're doing something for
the Boys and Girls Club down in South
flow in West Palm Beach we are i've
brought out a movie theater and all the
proceeds i'm doing a silent auction
bringing in different sponsors and all
the proceeds made will go to the Boys
and Girls Club in Palm Beach County yeah
that'll be fun that'll be fun so you'll
be there and introduce yeah I never put
my name on anything if I'm not there I'm
not a part of it don't use my name okay
well I also enjoy you on on CBS Sports
Net We Need to Talk you're rocking it
with Amy Trask and yeah Andrew Kramer
and a bunch of people have amazing catch
talking sports you sure do
uh you're welcome here anytime Lisa
please come back anytime thanks for
having me at Lisa Leslie on Twitter to
also follow Lisa Leslie who you can
check out an uncle drew I can't wait for
this to come out on the 29th of June the
Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern
on audience